Good Morning Hank!
It's Wednesday, August 31st
Apparently it's talk to someone other than your brother week
My shirt matches the boxes behind me- I'm gonna change.
Yeah, I think that's better, although
I wonder if we can take it down a button... nooo
So Hank I want to address the people  who have recently ended or will soon end their formal education
and enter what is known as the "real world"
Ok the first thing that you'll notice upon entering the real world is
that it is neither more or less real than any of the previous worlds you have encountered
But you'll likely notice that the real world does have this interesting mix of like, crushing monotony
and paralyzing terror. It's not a real world, it's more of a CMAPT world.
Like, there's the crushing monotony of waking up at the same time, sitting in the same traffic, going to the same
job and then coming home to pay the same bills with your only distractions being like, television
and video games and YouTube.
But there's also the constant paralyzing terror of knowing that if you somehow screw up sitting in traffic
or working at your job or paying your rent, you will be like, homeless and hungry and alone.
This is not to worry you or anything. I'm just telling you how it feels for a lot of people. I will say that adulthood
gets much, much better.
Speaking of which, last night my son puked on my face. Like, not on my shirt or on my shoulder or something,
but on my actual, like, sensory organs. Babies do this all the time, they're like little puke factories.
To put this in context, even though a baby threw up on my face last night and I slept for, like, two hours,
I would still rank last night as better than almost every night of the first two years after I graduated from college
So it does get better, I promise, but I know the crushing monotony and paralyzing terror can be a little bit
overwhelming, plus there's like a 20% chance that you're unemployed and like, a 100% chance that you're
underemployed. Like, unless you're in a successful time lord rock band, you're probably not doing what you want
to do everyday. How are you going to solve these problems? Two ways:
Number one: Time. These things take time.
Number two: You're going to get an Ilene.
So for a few months after I graduated from college, I worked as a student chaplain at a children's hospital.
Then I bummed around a little until I got a job at Booklist Magazine, where 90% of my job was typing ten digit
codes into a database.
Kind of crushing monotony to be honest with you, but I was surrounded by books and I had these amazing
coworkers, most of whom were much older than I was.
And they helped me to do all kinds of grownup things, like opening a checking account and not crying so much
when I would get dumped, which was frequently, but one of these colleagues at Booklist was a woman named
Ilene Cooper who's a writer. Ilene has published more than twenty books for children, from a picture book
about the golden rule to a biography of JFK to a new novel called the Angel in My Pocket that's just
absolutely delicious. One day I went into her office and I said, "I would like to take you out to lunch because
I am also a writer, and there is this book that I would like to write and it's going to be real good."
She said, "Okay", we went to the Cheesecake Factory and I was like, "I have an idea for a book.
It's set at a boarding school and in the middle, this thing happens, and then at the end, there's an ending."
And Ilene said, "That sounds great." Finally, early in 2002, I brought Ilene 40 single spaced pages and for the next
two years, she worked with me to turn those 40 single spaced pages into a novel that would eventually become
Looking For Alaska.
The only reason Looking For Alaska exists, the only reason I have a job writing books, the only reason there's
Brotherhood 2.0 or Nightfighteria is Ilene. Whoever you are, to get through the period of crushing monotony and
paralyzing terror, you need an Ilene. And it can't be me because for one thing, I'm already trying to be an Ilene
for a bunch of people, like Ransom Riggs, author of Miss Peregrine's Home For Peculiar Children,
I was kind of a little bit of an Ilene for him. Not as much of an Ilene as Ilene is, but a little.
So that's my advice for navigating the treacherous waters of life after school: Find someone who's doing
something you want to do better than you can do it, and listen to them. And you should really check out
Ilene's book Angel in My Pocket for the middle grade reader in your life. There is a link in the dooblydoo.
It's great. Not the link, the book. The link is just a regular link. I have signed 42,000 copies of your books and I am
going to continue but first I have to go the doctor because my hand isn't working right, and I've got to get
occupational therapy. I wish I were making that up.
Hank, I will see you on Friday.